la primera vacuna latinoamericana contra
el kobe 19 está más cerca así lo anunció
una alta funcionaria del gobierno cubano
avanzando pensamos que sobre un estaría
quizás
el expediente alzheimer todo lo que
lleva las evaluaciones un inicio de
inoculaciones que permite empezar a
pensar en una vacunación masiva para
agosto confían en haber vacunado a 6
millones de personas más de la mitad de
la población de la isla caribeña una
estrategia que esperan que para final de
año llegue al total de la población y
después para el resto del mundo y que de
ahí en lo adelante se pueda seguir
trabajando en la fabricación
vacunas no solo para cuba sino también
para países que ya han mostrado
determinado interés a nuestros amigos
del 6 b cuba tiene dos vacunas
candidatas en fase 3 soberana 2 y abdalá
se encuentran en una etapa de ensayos
clínicos que será combinada con estudios
de intervención con los que esperan
vacunar en mayo a 2 millones de personas
además están trabajando en otras tres
vacunas que están cerca de estar
finalizadas fruto del embargo que vive
la isla desde 1962 por parte de eeuu
cuba ha sido autosuficiente en la
producción de vacunas y el 80% de las
soluciones de su programa de
inmunización se producen localmente una
soberanía que llega a las vacunas contra
el cob y 19 idea y soberana el nombre de
dos de sus fármacos